For this video, I’m going to show you how
to escape from professional double-locking
handcuffs, without using anything but a standard
office paperclip.
Start by biting the small end of your paperclip
so there’s a little dent at the top near
the end, then unfold the side of the clip
to make a little handle. Hold the clip between
your 3rd and 4th fingers, and guide the head
of the paperclip into the keyhole, then use
the meaty part of your thumb to turn the makeshift
handle, and free your hand. Once you have
one hand loose, it’s really easy to get
the other one freed up as well. And in just
a few seconds, you’re out.
Now let’s take a look at how this works
mechanically. If we peek inside the cuffs
you can see there are triple stranded ratchets
that allow the cuffs to close in one direction,
but lock up and prevent the bar from opening
the other way.
When we insert a paperclip and turn inward,
you can see it catches on the ratchets and
pushes them down out of the way.
And by disengaging this mechanism, there’s
nothing holding the cuffs together anymore,
so they literally, fall right open.
Now the direction you turn the paperclip really
depends on which keyhole you’re working
on at the time. But as a rule of thumb go
in the top edge of the keyhole on the thin
side of the cuffs, then turn toward the wide
end of the cuffs to open them.
Now it’s a little more challenging to pick the
lock if you’re the one wearing them, especially
if they’re the hinged kind like these, but
with a little practice you can still gain
your freedom within seconds.
Now obviously handcuffs aren’t the most
complicated of locks, but that doesn’t mean
you should ever try escaping from the police.
If you do, it’ll actually make your life
a lot more difficult, so it’s just better
to respect the law, and stay out of trouble
in the first place.
But on the other hand, if you ever get kidnapped,
held hostage, or abused, it’s important
to have options. And there’s one more option
you need to know about, in case your handcuffs
have been double-locked.
The sides of these cuffs have two little pins,
and when they’re pushed all the way in,
they lock the handcuffs in place so they can’t
be opened or closed. Professional handcuffs
are made this way to keep the ratchets from
cinching up and causing nerve damage to prisoners.
And it also makes lock picking a little more
difficult.
Look closely at the keyhole when the pin is
pushed, and you’ll see the double-locking
mechanism slides into place at the bottom.
You’ll need to disengage the double-lock
first, by turning the paperclip the other
direction, until you hear it click. Then go
ahead and open the cuffs the same way as before.
That’s all there is to it.
Well know you know how to use a humble paperclip,
to escape from heavy-duty, professional grade
handcuffs. Just make sure you use your head,
and only use this technique, for entertainment,
or to bust loose from the bad guys. Well that's it for now.  If you like this video, perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com